un lundi après midi de septembre
comme tous les deux mois le service de
pmi de côte-d'or réuni ses personnels
plus d'une centaine de femmes qui
travaillent pour la protection
maternelle et infantile dans le
département parmi elles françoise
médecin isabelle infirmière
puéricultrice et marie hélène sage femme
date et surtout dijon cela nous permet
de nous retrouver pour discuter entre
nous sur le fonctionnement un petit peu
globale de la pmi et de situations
parfois un peu particulière qu'on veut
partager ensemble avec les collègues
puéricultrice donc ma collègue isabelle
les autres véhicules series de mai
sector on se voit assez régulièrement
mais les autres collègues sage-femme
mais les médecins souvent on les voit
que dans les temps de réunion il ya le
rural il ya la ville vlc mireval et nos
pratiques sont vraiment très différentes
les unes des autres et l'est pas on peut
être un petit peu mise un petit peu en
difficulté par une destination que voilà
qu'on ne rencontre pas là que nos
collègues déjà rencontré et ça peut être
un soutien pont alors au programme aussi
ce jour là le bilan des actifs des
femmes ont rencontré parce que 900 aux
futures mères les périodes trice vous
avez réalisé 7124 visites à domicile
voilà alors les consultations médicales
sans compter les visites dans les écoles
maternelles et c'est parti françoise y
consacrent plus d'un quart de son temps
il y à 25 écoles sur son secteur
elle y vient régulièrement pour faire
les bilans de santé des enfants de 4 ans
est-ce qu'il y en a qui se souviennent
de moi
oui d'accord et comment je m'appelle où
vous souvenez pas ça s'édifie libre à
vous mais tu as raison je m'appelle
françoise on a fait des jeux on a
regardé ses vous voyez bien si vous
entendiez bien vous avez bien grandi et
avec qui avec moi mon nounours qui
s'appelle pompon alors aujourd'hui je
vais voir quelques enfants mais
fattouche il y en a que j'ai déjà vu
l'année dernière il y en a que je vais
pas cette année au quai à dijon
l'accueil solidarité et familles du
quartier des grésillés isabelle et marie
hélène il débute une matinée de
consultation
[Musique]
une petite main dans sa connaissance
tous les tubes il boit tout lé compteur
après deux heures chaque de creuser
encore jerry louis hayes et il a dix
jours nick hayek que peu à 38 semaines
c'était un open bar
c'est à dire qui est il est alimenté en
revenus et était liquide quand ils
voulaient mais que là maintenant ben
voilà un homme qu'il faut que tu prennes
sourit-on va dire de sauverait aeria à
son rythme de petites sommes mais vous
beaucoup puissiez je te mords tenir dans
la durée il faut à notre hôtel
d'accord les petites sommes on te pose
sur la balance on te vole pas toujours
bien trois fils aux 535 regard du dans
ce que je lis ça parlera lyonnais ont
bien pris le petit chat web va très bien
mais isabelle s'inquiète pour sa maman
un marine elle est la vie personne tout
un accouchement
plusieurs professionnels de santé qui
consultent gratuitement dans le même
lieu un vrai plus pour les familles fini
à l'aise ici
si pour ça j'ai conseillé venir la
pierre mais c'est très pratique
voilà juste à côté de la maison voilà de
quartier
plus de 300 enfants et leurs mamans sont
suivis ici chaque année
[Musique]